from nick i'm michael me again oh this
looks like a related question what are
your thoughts on astrology
i'm currently living a single life so my
tinder inbox looks like someone's home
mailbox who went to mexico and never
came home
which is awesome however so many of
these babes are into astrology
and there is no filter yet to weed them
out my question is a is astrology real
and b if so should it be a turn off
because it's
well demonic correspondence an influence
over weak-minded women who want to find
themselves
thanks sincerely the not wanting to
shack up with fallen stars
i think you've answered your own
question nick uh but you do get the
point
this is probably one of my least popular
opinions but it happens to be correct
the problem with astrology my friend
josh
made this point the other day on twitter
the problem with astrology
and the reason that you should not
consult astrologers
is not that it is fake and silly and a
waste of your time
it's that it's real and it compromises
your free will so
so there is something to this now i'm
not saying that every
two-bit charlatan who's doing a palm
reading or something is actually telling
you your future
but i am saying that the idea of
astrology
is to
throw away one's entire free will and
try to get a leg up on
on reality and to try to make oneself
into a god in some ways and uh so i just
wouldn't do
it yeah it's bad now a lot of people
they say oh you know what's your sign
are you a sagittarius or whatever and
you know
i suppose that's all innocent enough as
long as you sort of discourage it and
get that gal going to church all right
if you do not
ring that bell subscribe to this video
then youtube will render me speechless
which is coincidentally the name of my
upcoming book it's going to be released
in 11 days speechless controlling words
controlling minds which is available now
for pre-order you got to get
those notifications you got to make sure
you don't miss a video and head on over
to apple podcast google play stitcher
spotify
gmail hotmail aol instant messenger
subscribe to the michael knowles show
audio podcast leave a five star review
see you next time
[Music]
you